so when you did get hired with the view
yeah is it a contract of do they pay in
the format of one episode is it a
six-month contract is it a three-month
contract what's the con
so i'm trying to remember my contract i
basically had a three-year contract but
at the end of each year they had the
opportunity they had to renew me got it
so um and there you had a guarantee of a
certain number of appearances i wasn't
employed at abc at large i was employed
by the view me personally megan may have
had a different deal how different is
that is that separate yeah because if
you're in it's actually much safer to be
employed by abc at large because then if
something goes wrong with the view you
can be utilized that makes sense it's a
larger corporation i didn't fight for
that because at the time frankly i don't
think i had the credentials to fight for
that and secondly
i wasn't sure how it was going to go and
i wasn't sure what was going to happen
so i was comfortable with the contract
they gave me enrolling in and was it
decent pay was it yes okay so it was a
raise which was great yeah this smile
says it says a story
are you still in touch with any of the
ladies on the view
whether it's the conservatives the abbey
huntsman's the mccains the the joy
behar's the whoopies i was um until this
appearance that just happened i mean i i
actually maintained a a pretty you know
decent friendship um with sunny with
sarah
occasionally would exchange with whoopi
and joy um
i my time on the show was actually okay
because even though we duked it out
sometimes on air we actually really got
along behind the scenes as a group it
was a cast that really liked each other
yeah so i left and even though i was
fired
um inexplicably overnight
um i didn't hold that against the cast
and there were people that worked there
at the time that aren't there anymore
that were responsible for that um but i
left kind of feeling
like these were still my friends and my
family and i was sad so i didn't trash
them in media i didn't do any of that
and it wasn't really until this last
appearance that i just felt like wow
that was pretty horrible what happened
on air because you guys knew what i was
going to say and i i really thought i
was there to have a conversation because
i know them you know sonny was at my
wedding you know i know these people and
i said if you're going to invite me and
you know what i'm going to say either
say forget it you're not coming on or
let me talk let's have the conversation
she's the biggest advertiser for the
view do you know like i don't know but i
know
you know big farm isn't it
sorry but can you google and see who's
the biggest advertiser on the view i
looked it up in 2015 a bunch of
advertisers dropped but that's not the
article i'm looking for i want as recent
as possible let me go back to it from
the day you got fired
how many days prior to that was when you
questioned hillary clinton oh i think it
was four i think i questioned her on a
thursday and lost my job
on a sunday oh it's i didn't know that
so so four days after you you questioned
hillary clinton so what happened there
was and i've spoken about this with um
you know
sunny recently that we were like no one
really understood what happened there
and i don't know if it's attributed to
the hillary clinton interview i really
don't i have no idea what year was that
20 was it 16 17 it's right around there
she was right still running about what
was it or after she lost no no she was
it was after she lost after she lost she
wrote a book called what happened it was
the first live appearance she did on the
view and she asked the question oh yeah
that's right i saw that yeah i asked the
question i had i had just re-upped like
that summer you know you had to like i
said they had to renew you even though
you had a three-year contract they had
to renew you so i signed the paperwork i
was like okay i guess i'm in for another
year and that's the way i view this
business you never know you could be out
tomorrow you know so i was like okay in
for another year
i asked what i thought was a pretty
benign question i asked her i said
listen you know you're saying you're
acting like you're surprised that trump
won but it sounds a little tone deaf to
me because i was talking to people
around the country who were disgusted
with a lot of what was going on like
looking back do you see that maybe these
people voted because they didn't like
what was happening in the prior
administration i thought that was a
pretty fair question
her face said otherwise i didn't even
get to ask about her emails which was
really what i would there was a little
bit of panic at the show that day
because i was like well can we show here
that she signed a piece of paper that
said she knows what these
classifications mean and she's denied
that she knew them but her signature and
they were like i wouldn't do that i
wouldn't do that there was a little bit
of worry that it was going to be
combative
but don't they like that is that like
the whole point of the view they want to
see unconsciousness no i think the
perception is that but actually i think
there's a lot of protection that goes on
on shows like that for political figures
for point of views
so i didn't get to that but i asked the
tone-deaf question and then four days
later i actually got a call from someone
who worked in media i think i think it
was oliver darcy actually if i'm not
mistaken who wrote who called me and was
like there's a rumor that like megan
mccain's taking your job and i was like
oh well that can't be i just i was like
what and i wrote my producer and he was
like oh we'll get on it pr i don't even
think the ep of the show knew
no one knew the ep of this so this came
from the highest
like candy and brian were like
really quite nice to me and were like
listen
i don't know and i believed them and i
still believe them because they're i
really do um
so i don't know what happened i don't
know if it's related to that i don't
know if that was the icing on the cake i
don't know if there were talks going on
and then suddenly someone decided oh
great and also that interview didn't
help i don't really know just the timing
seemed so awesome so when did you when
did you sign the next year what
was in the summer
summer how many like weeks or months
before the hillary clinton uh uh
it was in august i don't remember it was
several weeks before that oh so so this
is fresh so you sign it's not like it's
six months no no several weeks it was
several weeks got it so they had already
committed to having you on for another
year so it wasn't like behind closed
doors they were talking to megan
listen i maybe all i know i mean there
are people that have since been fired
from there that were doing pretty
horrible things that's come out in the
news um
who i think probably were being
underhanded about it in many ways i
don't know i don't know what
conversations weren't going on i just
it kind of changed my perception of
media because i always felt like a
contract was a contract and all of a
sudden i realized which was helpful for
the future like
okay you're here today you could be gone
tomorrow so just keep that in mind some
people would say just be happy you're
sitting here because maybe you pissed
off the wrong person you know because
there's certain people in politics you
don't piss off because they have a
reputation you know that's right and
that reputation is a multi-dimensional
type of a reputation if you know what
i'm talking about everyone off so i'm in
bad shape maybe i'll come work here
but we would love you so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye-bye
[Music]